in this video i'm going to talk to you
about how to sell a business and if
you're wondering who is this dude in his
mama's basement's closet wearing a wife
beater have anything to do with talking
about how to sell business how does he
even have the right the audacity to talk
about these things let me first make a
quick intro i've sold eight businesses
my name's alex ramsey i own
acquisition.com which is a portfolio of
companies that does over 100 million
dollars a year and i have nothing to
sell you and i make these videos because
i was once broke and wore these beaters
out of necessity rather than out of
choice and was in my mama's basement out
of necessity rather actually i'm not in
her basement this is a 5 million condo
in vegas but that's not the point i just
like working in places that have no
windows so i have sold eight businesses
over my career just to name a few of
them i sold allen which is a software
company that did 12 million in trailing
12 month sales i cannot disclose the
price that i sold to but that was the
top line revenue the nda is actually
fairly common in uh in sales agreements
especially of an appreciable amount of
money and the reason for that is because
they don't want a potential new acquirer
in terms of if you were to roll in other
companies after they buy your company to
know what you got for yours because then
it hurts their negotiating power now
that being said the next two companies
that i sold in 2021 i sold for 46.2
million dollars and i was able to do
that because i negotiated that in
because i was tired of not being able to
talk to the other one and so there's the
press release from that on top of that
you might be like well i don't have
businesses that big that's okay fear not
i also sold five brick and mortar
locations prior to this um and so i've
sold actually that's seven i don't know
why i said eight i shut down one there's
the there's the other one there you go
there's eight i had five brick motor
locations that i sold and here's what's
even cooler i've actually sold those
businesses to six different types of
buyers i sold to financial buyers so
private equity i sold two and family
offices that's what fo is so private
equity or family offices which is all
forms of private equity but
institutional buyers or family offices
second i bought i sold to strategic
buyers uh which is the one who bought my
software company i sold to friends i've
sold to competitors i've sold to
customers and i've sold to partners all
right so i've done a lot of these deals
and interestingly enough as it was going
on i never thought wow this is someday
going to come in handy in that i can
help other people go through this as
well because i've gone through all these
kind of weird scenarios all right and so
i've learned a lot in the process and i
would like to make this because i get
questions all the time about valuing
companies and buying companies and we
have companies that reach out to us so
for acquisition.com we work with
specifically service-based companies
especially internet service-based
businesses guru businesses e-learning
businesses course business etc we
purchase minority stakes in those
companies to help grow them which is
what the portfolio does now which is why
it does over 100 million that being said
we're very familiar with this process
and so i wanted to walk you through this
because a lot of people have questions
about it and so i'll walk you through
the overarching process and then i'll
dive into each of them in more detail
sound good awesome so phase zero zero is
the pre-requisites these are the things
that must be done or even even are
required for you to be able to sell or
have any kind of enterprise value to
begin with which i'm gonna be really
real with you most companies most
businesses are not valuable at all all
right most of them are just assets you
might have equipment uh you know if
you're a physical presence and if you're
an online business you have very little
value unless you have a lot of these
things in place all right so most people
want to try and go in business sell
their business and find out that no one
actually wants to buy it because people
are not stupid all right so next is once
you have these prerequisites which i'll
go over you have to find a bank or a
broker all right and this is something
that i've gone back and forth on i've
sold some of them without i've sold
something with i'll go pros and cons and
i'll explain to you kind of how to
negotiate that process and figure it out
after that now we can actually start the
selling process we have a bank we have
somebody representing us to help us go
sell our stuff all right and so this is
the prep this is phase one all right
phase two is now that we have prepared
all the stuff now we go market the thing
so that we can sell the thing to
somebody all right phase three is now
that we have people who want to buy the
thing now we got to close the deal all
right and so i'll walk you through each
of the intricacies of these and there
are honestly a lot of steps in this
process if you want to have a big number
money in the millions uh for a deal all
right so let's start at the top all
right prerequisite so these are deal
killers these are things that make a
deal not actually happen which i'll be
wrote with you is the vast majority of
time most companies are just not that
big and when i say this mind you i'm
talking about institutional sized uh
businesses so like if you want to have a
deal that's you know five million
dollars plus which is about the smallest
deal that any like real institutional
investor private equity family office
will will look at uh is there has to be
you know a big enough size for it to
make sense right now you you can have
tons of people who do you know a lot of
private investors and retail investors
people who just have a little bit of
money saved up they you know they might
want to buy a dry cleaning business they
want to drive by by a gym or they might
want to buy whatever right like those
are normal businesses but those aren't
that's not what we're talking about here
because those are all one-off and
they're not going to make you rich all
right and so that's why i'm focused on
the how to make you rich type sale
because these are much more difficult to
understand and the process is a little
bit more nuanced all right it took me a
long time to learn this and guess what
no one taught me this like i didn't see
this anywhere and it took me a long long
time it took me a year to just kind of
understand how the entire process worked
ended so that is what i'm trying to save
you is a year of painstaking effort and
i
have nothing to to sell you so like all
the people were trying to tell me had a
vested interest in trying to take
something from me and i don't know who
you are so i'm making this so that there
you go all right so the biggest one
though is that people are too small the
next one is that there's a customer
concentration meaning you have too few
customers that equate to the business
right if you have like 10 big customers
if two of them leave or three of them
leave all of a sudden you lose like a
third of your business that is very
risky all right people don't like that
and so they will give you a massive
discount on the value of business or not
even be interested because it's too
risky and especially if that's like
those relationships are there because of
you and they you know they like you and
you're the kind of relationship manager
which happens really commonly in small
businesses next one is no defined sales
process a lot of times people don't
really have an acquisition process for
getting new customers they don't know
how they get customers they just kind of
come their way and so if you don't have
a repeatable or reliable way of
acquiring customers ideally through
multiple channels which i'll cover in a
second you will probably not get a very
good multiple or even want to get any
kind of deal at all next is that when
you when people do start this process a
lot of the mistakes they make is they
don't go through enough potential
requires they're not trying to target of
people they're like i talked to 10
people and no one wanted to buy well no
[ __ ] you talked to people got to talk to
500. right and that's how you can get
somebody's going to give you uh the
right kind of uh multiple on your
business if you want to sell to an
institutional investor um next one's
getting timing wrong so everybody always
thinks that like man if i said another
18 months i cannot tell you the amount
of times like it's almost like the
the standard response of entrepreneurs
is i'll be ready in 18 months because a
year they know they're not ready but 18
months for some reason feels like it's
far enough out that they'll like somehow
magically have weight they're one and
all their problems will be done which is
not true all right so uh getting the
timing wrong is a huge issue and a lot
of people sell too late very few people
sell too early most people sell too late
in my opinion uh and in so doing they
can't sell it all and so the thing is is
i heard this quote from the uh the
managing partner of apg frasier preston
really really bright guy he said this on
one of our calls he said well business
is always going to go up in value over
time
except when it doesn't and in case it
becomes unsellable and so it was very
very interesting to hear that because
that is kind of the truth it's like
either people see this thing as like oh
wow this is a growing asset that's
increasing in value and even if you stay
the same for a period of time just more
years under your belt makes it actually
more reliable so it's less risky so
literally the older a business gets even
if it stays the same it becomes more
valuable right that being said if you
get the timing wrong as in it starts
going down no one wants to catch a
falling knife all right especially in
private deals like this stocks and
whatnot people are trying to time it
it's a big enough company it's been
around long enough et cetera that's
different than small businesses which is
what vast majority of people who are
watching this video have small business
being defined as less than 100 i think
employees next one you think it's worth
more than it is and this is a big one
right a lot of people are like man i
heard that you know so and so got 20
times top line it's like yeah and that's
because that's why it's newsworthy
because it's weird right it's not common
if there's a completed sale i think i
just can't remember where i pulled this
stat from the median uh number for uh m
a deals for for this was uh for five
million dollar plus deals i'm sorry i
can't remember what the median was shoot
i think the median was five million
dollars i can't i screw that the point
is that the multiple was 6.7 times
trailing 12 months and that is for
institutional buyers right now you might
not have an institutional buyer which is
why the vast majority of businesses that
get sold get sold in private deals for
like 1x 2x 3x and it's because they're
not really reliable businesses for the
most part they're just kind of asset
sales like i'm handing you know a
handful of employees over with some kind
of working model and i'm just moving on
to do other things which is honestly the
vast majority of businesses that get
sold it sold for almost nothing all
right so we hear about the big wins but
that's not the majority all right and so
i want to be clear in that most
businesses either don't get sold or get
sold for very very little money and so
the point of this presentation is how to
sell it for lots of money all right
which you have to meet these
requirements to even be considered okay
the next next little doodad that we have
on our list listicle here uh is not
growing
big enough tam or growth stores there's
three different things i put in one book
i needed to fit in one place all right
so if the business isn't growing you're
gonna get a big discount on it now i
said earlier that the longer business is
in place uh the more valuables which is
true but if you're not growing or you
don't have like ways of growing it or it
means that like the strategy you're
doing is no longer working people will
see that as a risk so if you have even a
tiny amount of decline people see that
as a big red flag because then they'll
extrapolate that into infinity on the
flip side if you have a tiny amount of
growth people do extrapolate that out
further so like flip it around and
sustain that growth for 12 months 18
months
prior to the deal to get a much better
number big enough tam so people might
think oh this is uh this this business
is cool it's a niche but it can't expand
beyond this niche so you need to have a
good growth story as in how are we going
to really 10x this thing because people
are buying not to buy your business
they're buying your business for what
they think the business will become all
right that's what kind of private equity
is all about no one's really trying to
buy the thing they want to try to buy
what things would it become all right
and so that's when you make great deals
right that's on their side so you have
to tell them or explain to them the
story of how it's going to work right
and the the more they can believe that
story that it's likely to occur then the
more valuable your business will become
next one and there's a huge one for
small business is key man risk as in
like are you the one who's the rainmaker
you're the one who's bringing in you
know all the deals are you the one who's
you know the special man who does all
the fulfillment all that kind of stuff
like are people coming for you if
they're coming for you then they're not
gonna come for your business which means
that when you leave the business is
worthless right and so you're a big risk
and a lot of times
uh this is i'll be frank with you in
acquisition.com we work with companies
that have key man and we work them over
the next three or five years to help
them not have keyman risk which is how
we were able to exit gym launch which
was started as kind of a more uh
guru-esque business and then transformed
into just a true uh business licensing
business at an enterprise level and so
there is a process of getting through
that and you have to take the time to do
it if you don't
your business will not be valuable okay
and then finally a single and there's
more risks these are just some of the
big ones uh single channel dependence
meaning you only have one way of getting
customers you have no other way and if
tomorrow that shut off you'd be screwed
people just imagine well if it shut off
then i would lose my money and good
investors don't take risks like that
they don't want to go to zero
and so that will massively impact the
value of your business all right so
these are deal killers these are things
that get you to not sell or sell for
very very little money and so you must
check off these boxes before you can get
big institutional money all right so
this is the big bottom line of that
section which is enterprise value is a
discount applied to future sales to
future sales
which means
you have to take the total amount of
sales that a business takes between now
and the end of time and then you apply a
discount to it which basically means
risk what's the likelihood that that
occurs all right and so if you can show
that you have a lot of future sales are
going to happen and it's very very
likely that they that they're going to
occur then you have a very very valuable
business if you have a small amount of
future sales or a declining amount of
sales then the likely that it happens is
low and the amount is also low all right
so that gives you low enterprise value
so that's the bottom line that's what we
want to show is we want to show that
we're going to make lots of sales and
continue to grow and the likelihood of
occurring is very very high they should
be asking you why are you selling this
business and you need to have a good
reason for it so
checked off that box let's go to phase
two let's say you check all those boxes
and you're like okay i think i have all
those things i now want to find it
banker or broker right and quick
difference here bankers are what you're
going to need to sell to an
institutional for the most part brokers
are usually when you're selling for less
than 5 million you get a broker and they
have different fee structures because
the amounts are lower and they have to
do more deals all that kind of stuff all
right and to be fair i think sometimes
bro being a broker is even harder
because you're selling [ __ ] let's be
real okay so uh the way that i did this
and so i'm just being real like the way
that i did this is that i network for
interest it's very hard i think you can
try it uh go you know google investment
banks google top whatever investment
banks and esp specifically
you'd want them in your market and your
size so there's two components it's you
know do they have they sold supplement
businesses have they sold e-commerce
businesses have they sold software
businesses have they sold elearning
businesses have they sold whatever type
of business you have number one and
number two how they sold them of your
size right if someone you know has sold
lots of e-commerce but they've only done
deals that are like 500 million and up
and you're doing like 10 million top
line you're not going to be fit for them
because the buyers that they already
know are not going to
want to buy your thing because the check
is too small all right and so these guys
write a proportion like checks
proportional to the fund size that they
have of the capital right like if you
have a billion dollars you're not going
to make a thousand dollar investment it
just doesn't make sense at the time
investment makes no sense all right so i
use my network which means i just called
everybody i possibly knew and said hey
do you know anybody who knows anything
about this and so you can start with
entrepreneurs you can start with people
you can start with your actual bank
where you go like actually to do banking
and you just pull threads and this is
what took me a long time which is why i
make this video to hopefully save you
guys some time is that like networking
to try and find these introductions was
a pain i didn't i don't know anybody you
know i mean like i wasn't born into an
investment bank so i have no clue and so
you network for introductions to these
banks okay
once you have that that uh some
introductions right
you you then give them a one-page
summary document you send them because
they'll be like okay well send me send
me a a a teaser right it's like a sizzle
sizzle page of like all the sexy things
about your business the assets your
lists how you you know it's just
literally a one-page summary that should
look really sexy that someone can look
at and be like i would like to take
another call with these people that's it
that's the objectives just to get them
to say yes i'll take a call with you
once they say yes i'd like to take a
call with you you then basically sell
them
on selling your business all right so
you sell them on selling your business
and then if they do like that they will
usually fly out to you
and meet with you in person with a team
and then they will sell you on why they
should sell your business and so the
process here goes like you network for
as many introductions you can to bankers
who are relevant to your size and your
space you send them the one page teaser
so that you can get them uh interested
they then a certain percentage of those
will take a phone call of the phone call
you sell those people and why it's a
good deal they will then follow up with
you and say yes i think it's a good deal
let's talk uh let's talk in person
you'll then probably meet with you know
four to six bankers um to tell you why
they think they would be the best ones
to represent you and get you the highest
enterprise value and that's where you're
going to negotiate their fee structure
and you're going to be asking them
questions around what other deals like
yours they have sold and what their
network looks like now they're all going
to say they know all the people and all
the decision makers and all the things
right but the real thing you want is
people who have sold businesses similar
to yours in terms of market and size in
recent history all right because that
means that they are it's recent they're
in the know it's not like they sold
something three years ago that was
similar because they're way out of way
out of touch all right you want people
who do this type of deal all the time
now the typical fee structures what else
what to watch out for so the their fees
and agreements they usually have an
upfront amount sometimes that's all
these things are negotiable you can
negotiate that out you can go shoot it
in they usually ask for upfront if they
if the number is lower
so if they don't think that it's likely
that they're going to sell they'll ask
for an upfront which you can use at a
negotiating point which is like do you
don't think you can sell it because then
it gives you a point to argue back to
somebody else right they'll give you
targets
uh for what they think they could sell
for and then they will give you ratchets
which is like and if we sell for over x
we get x percent we sell for over y we
get z percent what bankers will actually
do is once they will help you package
the business and they will go out to
market and they will pound the pavement
and they will talk to hundreds of buyers
and they will walk you through this
process but it's good to have an
understanding of this process by and
large
so that you cannot sound like an income
poop when you're talking to them all
right there's usually also a breakup fee
which you can negotiate out of the deal
or at least decrease it and you can also
on the flip side have minimums which is
like if you guys don't sell me if you
don't get an offer above
x then you don't get paid at all right
and so we had minims in our deals so
that they wouldn't actually get paid so
they're super incentivized so the things
that like you really want to uh be
cognizant of uh is is the minimums and
especially how they're going to get paid
like what number they're getting paid
off are they getting paid off the total
enterprise value or they're going to get
paid off the cash you receive right you
want to negotiate off the pass you
receive not the enterprise value because
let's say you sell 10 of the company for
a billion dollars i'm saying for you
know silly math so you'd get 100 million
bucks if let's say they got four percent
of enterprise value right they would get
40 million of the 100 million all right
so there's little things like this that
they will use to [ __ ] you all right so
like be cognizant of these things and
the targets and the ratchets that they
put in place it sounds like it's um
you want them to be really excited to
push it but the things that i really
would want you to pay attention to are
going to be the minimums and what
they're getting paid off of and breakup
fees and upfronts all right because at
the end of the day you know the ratchets
and targets hopefully you're happy with
this on the front end because what
happens sometimes is the reverse which
is people all of a sudden start hearing
the lois and whatnot and start getting
greedy um and i don't think that's why
it's like decide write down a number
before you start the process and talking
to all these guys because they'll blow
your mind up and they'll tell you that
you're gonna sell for a billion dollars
and then you sell for not a billion
dollars okay for much less less than
that so write down the number write it
to a letter to yourself and say i would
accept this for this reasons all right
because this is one of the most
emotional processes you can possibly go
through it's selling a part of yourself
selling part of your identity and so you
can get tied up in it okay now
you will sell your company better than
almost any banker right so they are
going to be experts in the process you
will be the one who's going to be an
expert at selling your company
especially if you're a promotional
entrepreneur you know how to sell right
and so you want to be very instrumental
in giving them the selling store because
they're going to be the ones who are
doing the selling but you're also going
to be doing selling as well so you need
to be
giving them the salient points you think
that they're going to say that they're
experts at this they're not that like
even though they've sold a handful of
companies they've only sold a handful
right they just sold five like yours
that's still a ton just like yours but
you want to have the really selling
points that only you will know because
they don't know your business right you
got to give them the really sexy stuff
all right
and as a reminder these people are like
real estate agents they're trying to
sell both sides they're trying to get a
deal done more than the best deal even
though they have ratchets even though
they have these things the big thing
they're trying not to do is not close a
deal and so they will do everything they
can to get both sides to just meet in
the middle and sell but that's not
necessarily in your best interest okay
so just remind you here it's not
necessarily your best interest all right
now
this was the false belief that i had
which is they will know what they're
doing and we'll get you the best deal
which is not true which i just explained
this and so this is the negotiating
point this is a writer downer for you
they only responded and i had to learn
this the hard way to if i don't get this
point the deal is off
otherwise they basically just steamroll
you and you might say like well maybe
you had bad banking experience who knows
but i'll just tell you this is my
experience is that you have to be
willing to walk away
from the table
in order to get the best deal all right
which is why you win negotiations before
you start them by having options all
right you want to have an amazing
business you want to have a business you
don't want to sell that's the best way
to sell a business is to not want to
sell it right and you have to get there
if you're like i would just get rid of
this thing for nothing then prepare be
prepared to get rid of this thing for
nothing because it's because it's going
to get there because they're going to
drill you because these are professional
negotiators on the other side table
that's what they do all day long you
might have sold your business one time
they buy businesses every [ __ ] day
all right so they know exactly how you
feel they know exactly how to manipulate
your emotions to get you to say yes to
lowest price okay so
what you want to say here is that if i
don't get this the deal is off and it
took me a really long time to learn this
and then all of a sudden when i started
speaking in this language the banker
started responding to me like oh no this
is really a big deal for them like if
they don't get this then all of a sudden
they start negotiating for me because
what will happen in this world of
institutionals they just say no to
everything unless you say you're going
to walk then they're like okay fine
we'll give you that one right so they
will just say this is our deal structure
unless you take it or leave it unless
you say i'm willing to walk on these
points all right and then they will
start moving just my observation now
i'm telling you i'm sharing this stuff
because don't share this with me all
right so uh we covered finding the
banker uh how to negotiate the fees uh
what to look at in terms of how to
interface with them to negotiate on your
behalf now let's start the actual
process all right so there's the prep
and this is a big big picture of what
the what this whole process looks like
once you've got audited financials once
you've got a sim which is a shoot i
don't even know
it's something model i think but
basically it's like this hundred page
plus thing of really in depth of the
financials and the story and the
competitive analysis and the marketplace
and the growth trajectory and all the
stuff that's what they should be doing
for you all right they should make that
thing
and they will send
the the the teaser out to all the you
know 500 people of those people a
certain percentage will sign ndas which
is non-disclosure agreements because
then because it's anonymous they won't
they won't when you're sending out the
teaser it doesn't disclose what the
company is that way you know employees
and things like that don't get scared by
you just shopping the company all right
so
this is how i recommend doing so you
have 500 buyers contacted and you'd want
to ask these questions how many buyers
are we contacting how big is your list
what are what are your potential
requires right
98 uh ndas from there you'll usually get
like 14 or so iois 15 right uh from
there about half of those uh you'll do
kind of like management presentations
from there you'll get two to four lois
and ios indication of interest which is
non-binding and loi is also typically
non-binding um but it's a letter of uh
of interest which is like this is what
we're prepared to pay for the business
from there you negotiate them against
each other and then you get one deal
right and then you you sign the loi and
then you go through the diligence
process and then you close okay that is
how these sales numbers break down if
you've talked to 10 people then lo and
behold you probably are not going to get
a good number right and so that's how
this process works the thing is a lot of
these guys are lazy so you have to push
them on these numbers to send out more
like repeat follow up with these people
and i'll be honest with you on the deal
that we ended up doing it wasn't uh the
first set of buyers that we got to the
table it was actually somebody that my
cfo pushed our bankers to follow back up
with again that ended up being the the
final acquirers all right so like you
want to push them because at the end of
the day they're going to try and do as
little as possible to get paid i'm just
being real with you that's the real
world all right so let's do it
so now that we have to understand the
sales process works this is now you're
working with the bankers you got to get
this prep stuff done so you got to get
your due diligence in you got to get
organized a lot of people don't have
this stuff draft of the sim there it is
confidential information memorandum all
right so you got to complete that get a
review that's a huge amount of work all
right
and these weeks are just rough all right
these are rough amount of weeks all
right i'm going to show you 20 weeks in
this presentation but like that whole
pre-process of getting the bankers took
another like three months so i would say
roughly from the time you start this
process the time you get a check in your
bank account is usually 12 to 18 months
all right i'll say 12 is a nice like if
you're like if today you decided you
wanted to buy it would take a year
before that actually you'd have a check
in your bank account all right so then
they're going to put together the list
of potential buyers or investors
then they're gonna have the summary fact
sheet and the confidentially
the nda is agreed upon
and then that's it that's the prep phase
all right that's it simple simple all
right now we start marketing because we
got all the materials done now we market
them okay
so now we contact those perspective
buyers we go neat uh teaser then nda
then you get which is the one to three
page blind description of the business
then the data room which is basically
like they have to put the stuff like in
the cloud so that people can always have
access to it so all these potential
buyers will be sifting through all your
your resources to come up with questions
that they're going to ask you or say
that's not a good deal for them right
this is when you have your kind of your
pitch deck right of what you're going to
present to them right you're going to
dry run practice it etc potential
investors will then submit their ios all
right that's the indication of interest
that they're like we might be interested
in buying this business and they'd give
a rough range right and then
you have potential people who are i'm
trying to go through this part faster
because it sounds boring but this is the
stuff this is how it works right so
potential investors visit company they
provide you provide access to the data
room of all the diligent stuff that
they're going to need so they have a
cursory idea of what they need and you
do the data room so you have to do all
this interaction just put all the [ __ ]
up there and they can all have access to
it and then when you start on the the
actual uh offers which is here week 18
final offers received and evaluated
strategy is determined for moving
forward with final parties right
so this is where you bid them back
against each other and then you get
final offers which is lois okay letters
of intent okay
now once you have the letters of intent
and you've bid them back together you're
gonna have different deal structures are
gonna be presented to you which i think
is covered here okay so you start
negotiating those you go back and forth
et cetera now here's the thing
there's the price
and then how it's paid it's price and
terms and i can't tell you like getting
good terms is worth discounts right now
it depends on what you're selling if you
just want to sell to have a story and
that's one thing but if you're starting
to get rich then the terms matter a lot
all right so people share a big number
like for example if i wanted to say i
sold
you know gym launch prestige ops for a
hundred million dollars i could have got
100 million dollars
in paper all right so hear me out so if
i said hey
pay me 25 million earn out if we do a
billion dollars this year in sales
sure they'll sign it and then i could
say that added 25 million to my
enterprise value on the sale i will be
transparent with you i had no seller
financing i had no earn out i had no i
did do i did real equity because i sold
66
and i had no transition services and no
consulting all right and that was
because that was the that was the agreed
upon way that i wanted to sell this
business and i said that up front to
everybody i said this is a full
uh leadership exit i will not be
involved i will not have transition
because the thing is if they're like
sure if you just keep working for the
business for two years yeah we're fine
selling to you it's like well i might as
well just own the different thing right
and i'll just grow it myself right and
so this is where uh this is important
now mind you acquisition.com for example
for our business we only do minority
investments because we want the
leadership team there so we actually
want to just participate in the growth
and help grow the companies from 3
million to 10 million to 20 million to
50 million and beyond right we want to
participate in the growth and we're
happy taking a smaller life of what we
consider to be a bigger pie rather than
ripping out the management right so
we're we work with people who are like
not not really ready for institutional
yet but want to get that 20 million
dollar 50 million 100 million plus exit
i'm gonna get them ready just for
context all right so these are the
things that will discount you so if you
had 100 million dollars for example for
an exit they might say okay well we're
going to put 25 million in earn out 25
million is going to be seller financed
you're going to roll 20 which is 20
million so there's 30 million left uh
and so we'll give you 30 million in cash
uh and you say oh i sold my company 100
million right and then of the 30 you've
got the bonuses and you've got other
equity you know partners if you have
those and then you've got the tax man so
all of a sudden let's say you've got 20
that's given to your team so now you're
at 24 million and then taxman takes his
30 right uh and you've got closing fees
and things like that and escrow fees uh
and so now you're at uh
whatever 18 17 million so you sold your
business for 100 million dollars we only
got 17 million bucks right
that's why this stuff matters okay so
you want to make sure that you know why
you are selling and what the most
important things are for you and you
need to ruthlessly ruthlessly
communicate that to the bankers okay
very important point because they will
negotiate on those points for you now
the things that they're also looking for
for them is is it's a fit within their
their portfolio like a family office for
example is just going to buy something
that they think is a good cash flow
investment and price is going to be very
important to them a strategic buyer
would be somebody who's going to be
let's say let's say you own
a car wash you know chain or whatever if
there's a bigger car wash chain that
just wants to buy yours they'll give you
a better multiple because
they already have all these systems in
place so they're going to make more
money from your business than just a
generic buyer will so the ideal way to
exit is to strategic because you'll get
the best multiples but to be fair there
are more financial buyers than there are
strategic so that's kind of the
trade-off okay
and you want to make sure that that your
business is in good hands so that you
want people who have relevant experience
we were very fortunate that the people
that we felt were most equipped to buy
the company were also the ones who ended
up giving us the best offer and so
that's that doesn't happen we were very
fortunate end up working out that way
for us um but this this it doesn't
always happen that way and then this is
a really simple one do i like these
people will my team like these people
because ultimately the team's gonna be
working with them right so you wanna ask
those questions as you're going
throughout all right so like you can
have [ __ ] who pay you a little bit
more and then really nice guys who pay a
little bit less
life's short man so like i would go with
people who
a lot of people regret just taking the
highest offer rather than 10 less and
having a much better life okay
at this point you would sign your loi
all right most of the times it's gonna
be exclusive saying like
if you have a tremendous amount of
interest you might be able to sign lois
and have them not be exclusive and they
still bid all the way up to the purchase
agreement most times that's not the case
they don't want to they don't want to
expend the money so like the so apg when
they bought us spend probably about a
million bucks in diligence just in
diligence right to figure out whether
our company is worth buying right and
again you're not going to attract guys
who are going to write 100 million you
know do a million dollars in diligence
for a 5 million deal it makes no sense
right so like if you want big money
numbers you have to you got to follow
the big money process all right so
at this point you signed an exclusive
loy meaning you can't shop the business
to anybody else during the period of the
of the due diligence now
i'm gonna say at the end but i'm gonna
say it again all right and i've got a
special treat for you which i'm now
remembering uh at the end of this video
i'll actually i videotaped us actually
having the escrow hit and the final
signing and you can actually see it go
down for real all right it's very
anticlimactic
but you can see it for real and now see
what a 50 million dollar cell looks like
okay so the due diligence will begin
they're going to try and negotiate time
saying like oh we can get a faster close
if blah blah blah if you accept the
slower price [ __ ] they're going to
take as long as they want literally
ignore it they seriously they will try
and use speed i had every single person
try to use speed as a selling point i
thought it was legit the first time they
said 30 day close and it took sorry they
said four i said 30-day close and it
took 112 days and i i accepted worse
this is on one of the other companies we
sold i expected worse terms on that
right so the next time i came around
this is why i'm giving you this stuff
next time i came around they were like
oh we could do a fast because i was like
whatever take your time my company's
grown do whatever you want right and
when you do it that way you're in the
position of power okay
so
they're gonna audit your quality of
earnings which is something you have to
get the bankers will explain how to do
that which is to make sure that your
numbers are legit that they are what you
say they are right anybody can put
numbers in exactly but are they for real
right
then they'll do legal diligence so
they're gonna make sure you actually own
the company do you have any lawsuits
against you are you in
are you go are you breaking any laws
which actually is fairly common when it
comes to claims and things like that uh
for like ftc things like like it's it's
actually fairly common so you want to
make sure that stuff and that stuff can
blow deals up i had a an acquaintance of
mine that had uh two different deals
blow up that were like nine figure deals
multiple years apart because they were
not compliant all right so like and they
thought that the lack of compliance was
one of the reasons that they were so
successful and so they didn't want it as
too risky all right
what they'll then do is they'll start
interviewing your customers all right
this may sound freaky but that's what
they're going to do they're going to
talk to your customers they're going to
talk to your employees they're going to
interview them the firm that purchases
spent like 250 000 i'm pulling that
number out of air but it's a lot on
research
uh to to see what the what your
customers think about you so if you're
terrified to think about what your
customers who who are past customers who
no longer pay you think about you be
prepared right they're gonna talk to
them be like should i buy this company
is this a good company right what has
your experience been like right and same
thing uh with your employees now they're
not gonna ask them but the that stuff
they're gonna only talk to people
already know about the deal but they're
gonna interview them really uh heavily
to see what's your involvement is he
really is he really passively involved
like what do you do on a daily basis
what do they do on the daily because
they want to know that if you leave it's
still going to keep going and growing
all right
then you've got background checks of you
and your management team to make sure no
one's you know a convicted criminal or
something sketchy
which more realistically is like
financial fraud employment contracts to
make sure that if you leave they don't
all leave with you or they're like only
there for you etc and you're like okay i
feel like i'm done nope there's more
okay so once you've gone through this
whole diligence process which takes 60
to 90 days now if you're tracking with
me there was like three months you know
of looking for bankers and figuring that
part out and making sure that your
business is ready may take much longer
than that but like assuming your
business is ready right and you have met
the prerequisites it might take you 12
weeks to find the right bankers from
there it's 20ish weeks to get to this
point and then you might have another 60
to 90 for intelligence now bankers will
say that it's going to take less time
they're incentivized to tell you that it
takes less time so i was talking to a
good friend of mine who was like hey man
i got they said they're 30 day diligence
uh and they quit close and i was like
dude it's not gonna happen and it was
for a nine figure number right
and lo and behold 90 days later he was
like
yeah fast they said wrong they were
right he's like why didn't you tell me
this was gonna be so much fun right and
he's now i think like
five months into his process of post
post agreement signed right so like i'm
not saying that that's typical but i'm
saying like you need to be prepared for
a year like and it's going to be a year
slog and a lot of your focus is going to
go to this process so like
you really need a strong management team
a place who can continue to grow the
business without you all right other and
that'll prove the point and this is a
note
the longer the process takes it is in
the buyer's advantage that take a long
time all right so you want a fast close
they want a slow close and being real
the only way to speed up the clothes is
to keep growing like crazy because they
then they're going to realize that all
of a sudden the valuation from the
beginning to the end will have changed
and then you will have much more
negotiation power and you can break the
agreement and get other offers right so
important point there now so once you've
gotten that point you'll get a purchase
agreement
inside of the purchase agreement you'll
have these different pieces you have to
watch out for indemnities are the things
that you're reliable for these are the
things that will keep you up at night
you need to negotiate hard on these
things now give the things that are
reasonable like yes like fundamental you
know indonesia uh warranties i think is
the name of the clause whatever it's
like you actually own the company you
actually own the trademarks like yes you
have to like yes otherwise the whole
purchase is off right and you could be
liable for the total purchase amount for
that stuff right now that's the
indemnities but the other indemnities
are things that like are completely out
of your control so you want to make sure
you negotiate those things out and again
with all these negotiations you have to
be willing to walk away and say like
i don't like if this bullet's in there
the deal is off like and if you can't
say that you're gonna get raked over the
calls okay now non-competes depends on
why you're selling and what you want to
do next but you want to be very specific
and this is one of the hardest things
that that you're going to get into
negotiating especially if you have a
skill if you're really good at you know
trash compacting they're going to not
want you to touch anything trash related
for a long period of time all right and
what's really tricky about this is that
if you roll equity into the new company
that they're going to be buying your
your company in or whatever
they will write in the articles of
incorporation that none of the people
who have that can compete and so even if
you have a purchase non-compete you may
have a non-compete as long as you are an
equity holder in that other company
which means that if you want to breach
or not compete you would have to give up
the equity that you rolled in addition
to
uh the the the that's once the other
noun could be expired so you have to be
very very careful about how these
non-competes are written and the
definitions that you have around this is
so important like i can't tell like so
for example if you were selling let's
say a skincare line they might say they
they the wri the first one you get might
just say like you can't be in beauty
anymore well that'd be freaking
ridiculous right because you know the
space and you're not competing with your
company if instead of skincare you start
getting into makeup right and you have
to make that argument right it depends
on the size of the deal and what you're
willing like if this is the one deal
that's going to seal all deals for you
then maybe you'll be willing to give
more right and be like all right i'm not
going to touch the space for a long time
right on the flip side if you're like i
already know what my next thing's going
to be and this is the best thing to do
with the non-competes is know what
you're going to do next because if you
know what you're going to do next then
you can be very specific with the
language and you can make sure that
you're 100 covered and just tell them
that's what i plan on doing next i just
want that to be affected and if you say
that and i'm telling you guys the best
way to negotiate these things is to be
honest just tell them what you want and
a lot of times it's much easier than
trying to guess and ascribe blame and
all that kind of stuff all right
schedules is all the stuff that you
provide it's basically another word of
like proof right we're doing all this
based on these assumptions and the
assumptions have to be true for some
reason the schedules are not there like
we did this based on this you know
customer segmentation analysis if you
mentioned it in the selling process of
getting them to say yes and negotiating
but then you don't include it in the
agreement as a schedule it's as though
it didn't happen and then they can come
back and screw you now this all sounds
scary most of the times these agreements
don't get repealed all right but you
want to make sure that you include all
the stuff and that stuff sucks but you
got to do it you got to have a good
lawyer for it all right definitions
this is kind of interesting as a total
philosophical point the agreement itself
is is almost as long as the pages of
definitions for the terms that are used
in the agreement and i think socrates
said wisdom begins with the definition
of terms and so like fundamentally the
agreement is like party a
as defined by x agrees to pay
y
according to these terms two parties z
according to these terms according to
you know uh for this amount according to
you know whatever so it's like all these
things are just terms that have to get
defined and so
i'll give you an example um
term that we were able to redefine i
think it was um actually i think we
redefined a term within the non-compete
that dramatically changed the the
meaning of the document and made it much
better for us to do whatever we wanted
to do next and so like just changing the
definition of a single word can run
through an entire agreement and
sometimes rather than fighting on
clauses it's better to really
narrow down the definition of what
you're trying to define so the scope
might be
geography for non-computer it might be
like there's a million things they
define in these documents but making
sure that you read the definitions for
what these words mean is really
important all right now
the few points and this is just the
points that you'll want to negotiate
there's a zillion other things these are
the main the big hitters
networking capital since the very end
you've already agreed on everything
already agreed on the terms you already
get in the price
right now you have to on networking
capital which is how much money you're
going to leave in the business right and
this is we're going to try it they're
going to try and get you there too right
it's like hey let's say you've got a
million bucks of working capital in the
bank account they're going to be like
well you've had a million dollars
sitting there for a whole year so that
comes with the business you're like well
i've just had it there because i didn't
take dividends out of it which why by by
the way is a good reason to dividend out
stuff and keep you know little in the
bank account if you're a smaller
business now if you're reinvesting and
buying and doing mma and stuff then
that's a different question which most
of you guys aren't doing that right now
so that being said networking capital is
what how much money is required to run
this business so that when we have this
transition it can continue to work as
normal right and you want that to be as
little as possible so that is so that
you can take as much of that cash to the
bank account in addition to what they're
going to pay you all right
and then finally is the escrow amount so
let's say you've got that 100 million
deal like i said earlier and they might
say we want to keep 20 in escrow all of
a sudden you've got 20 million in escrow
and again we still have the escrow we've
got the seller financing we've got the
urn out we've got the splits that you
have we've got taxes we've got we've got
all these other things that are going to
come out of it all right is you gotta
make sure it makes sense and so escrow
amounts like if you can keep it under 10
you're rocking all right now they're
going to probably keep some of it there
and that's because
they keep that as insurance like if
something else comes up or there's some
bill or blah blah that's your fault some
back taxes whatever they take it out of
the escrow amount all right that's how
they do and then usually they will
release that and again when they release
it they can release it in phases so i
think we had i think there was like a 90
day and then a one year for ours but
like it can change some people have
escrow that holds for two years some
people don't have any escrow but it's a
negotiating point all right
and i'm repeating this don't let speed
be a negotiating tool used against you
all right it doesn't matter they're
gonna take as long as they want so don't
let them use that against you all right
finally
you've done all this stuff you've
negotiated all the the hard points
you've gotten here and it's now payday
all right so
first off it's very anticlimactic
because it takes all this time and then
all you do see is just like a big
deposit in your bank account you're like
oh well i guess i am the same so i'm
just telling you that's what's gonna
happen all right that being said you
actually don't even sign papers there's
so many papers that you actually have to
pay someone to sign up because it takes
so darn long so we actually paid our
attorneys and i think it took like six
hours just to sign on our behalf for all
the documents and and do that for us all
right now once all the documents are
received by the escrow company both
parties have signed everything
at that point they initiate the deposits
to the parties that have already been
predefined so if you have payouts that
go to let's say your bankers or brokers
that comes off the top if you have
payments that go to the escrow company
comes off the top if you have
distribution that come to your employees
or other equity holders or investors
that then all comes and then you get
your piece all right and so uh to uh
to and just hold on because i'll show
you the actual video it's only like i
think 30 or 40 seconds of the actual
signing moment uh for us and you can see
what it really looks like to close a 50
million deal
but just a few closing thoughts on this
is that they're gonna treat you like you
don't know anything all right and so you
gotta get smart you gotta read stuff
watch this video re-watch it and
understand the pieces that someone's
going to try and do to screw you over
all right and you know a trust is going
to be a big component of this right so
like you have to trust the people that
you're going to do business with and if
you don't
it's going to be really difficult now
that being said you can trust them but
you still want to verify right you still
want to make sure that the words say
what they say they say and a lot of
times that's not the case all right and
so big picture if you do get to this
point congratulations it's very very
hard to to to grow a business do all
this stuff and sell to an institutional
buyer who will pay you know tens of
millions or hundreds of millions of
dollars for a company um these are just
some of the lessons that i learned and
this is the process it took me a long
time to even just figure out how it
worked um and for mozy nation i make
these videos because i no one told me
this stuff and so i'm hoping that for
you guys this helps you out and uh and
hey if you're doing over three million
you can hit us up and we'll see what we
can do to help you out and help walk you
through the process just so you know
this is the actual video of us
giving the final word
and seeing a 50 million deal go down in
the real world um between us and the
lawyers and the private new firm so it's
all there uh enjoy it
and so
uh if you could confirm that uh you
release your signature pages
uh contemporaneously with the release of
the stellar signature pages
we will be done on our side
okay confirmed
great
elizabeth yep we are we're good
confirmed
okay
great and and alex can you can you
confirm your release of signature pages
um contemporaneously with the buyer's
signature pages such that we can close
confirmed
great
well congratulations everybody um just
in time for uh for a nice weekend
hopefully i'll you know turn it over to
fragile or alex if they want to say any
words but um congratulations
yeah
alex is layla on oh yeah yeah right here
she's right excellent
great okay good well guys
congratulations it's a big milestone
um we're happy to be here with you
and um
you know i know this has been like a
long road and
we're happy to be at the
at the starting line here
so are we we're excited for uh for the
future and uh
we have
so many it's gonna be fun to announce it
to the team on i think monday and
tuesday so we're stoked
it's gonna be a good it's gonna be a
good next phase it's gonna be a good
kickoff year for everyone yep
anyways lots of love everybody see you
in the next video keep being awesome